[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
[Musique]
alors hier soir il ya des zones
interdites zone interdite 1,5 million
téléspectateurs plus faible score
historique pour zone interdite depuis
novembre 2016
ils ont pris une tôle as et pourtant je
l'aimé bien moi j'aime beaucoup zone
interdite et j'aime beaucoup aux filles
voilà qui est très sympathique ophélie
j'ai rencontré trois fois hier soir dans
zone interdite on a suivi des jeunes
c'est participer pour la première fois à
la nouvelle version du service militaire
le fameux s est venu service national
universel qui va être obligatoire pour
tous les jeunes de plus de 15 ans dès
2021 des jeunes qui ont donc eu la
chance d'être emmenés en guyane de la
navale amazonie pour leurs essais nous
vous allez voir qu'il ya une jeune fille
il n'a toujours pas compris où elle
était un petit peu comme eric naulleau
dans tpm peut regarder que j'avais
pendant des jours c'est dossal même
ampleur regardez là masoni française et
l'un des derniers poumon vert de la
planète
impressionnant ce qui se passe chez vous
et la nuit
dans la forêt amazonienne comme
saisonniers sur des calicots la série
comme celle là alors quand tu pars en
colo au service militaire tu touches
toujours sur un instructeur c'est vrai
voilà moi j'ai moi je vous rappelle
quand je parte en colo il y avait
toujours des mecs qui voulait faire les
malins
l'idée vous réveiller à 4 heures du
matin moi je me rappelle il m'était dans
la neige tout ça c'est terminé mal truc
je me rappel après mais il appelé mes
parents je me rappelle combien de fois
ça c'est arrivé ça vous est jamais
arrivé sa mémoire mais bien sûr ah ouais
c'est normal qu'on ait une vacance on
est perçu en 4 heures du matin à bien
vous étiez passage peut-être russe était
qu'est ce que vous faisiez jeu sans
déconner je me suis déjà voilà et cyril
bonnet successeur sans raison nancy
c'est sans raison sérieusement le
malheureusement ce qu'on a dit m
ils étaient ni passer le mien il lisait
encore catherine voilà je lisais encore
des bouquins ballon mais sans rigoler et
donc là la structure il va venir te
réveil à 5h du matin au volant alors que
toi t'as kiffé que tes potes jusqu'à 4h
bic et fracasse le gars il vient et il
va les allées voir que selon
l'instructeur c'est pas la même
technique de réveil vous me direz
laquelle vous préférez regarder
[Musique]
et ce bonjour la tenue du jour s'est
maintenue vous l'avez vu vous l'avez vu
[Applaudissements]
très bons souvenirs ont été ravis à
cette heure parce fuchs mais alors vous
avez remarqué en tunisie que je dors
jamais les abeilles mais franchement
jamais ta croyants voilà où ferme
envoyer des cv ça me tue ne dort jamais
jamais isabelle morini bosc
vous avez réalisé votre rêve ultime ce
week-end vous êtes passés sur m6 pour
elle c'est encore plus fort quand même
d'aller faire les cent vingt deux ans à
la cipressa nga top départ lâcher les
chevaux
c'est un nouveau jeu sur les courses
hippiques alors isabelle était capitaine
d'équipé aux côtés de deux candidats
les actionnaires qui peut encore perdu
alors on a encore eu la preuve qu
isabelle c'est une snipers l envoyé de
laval ont des trucs de ouf
regardez
non je déconne à regarder oui la police
et le voit bien il est content d'être là
gilles n'est pas sage si vous n'êtes pas
et où vous sortez les menottes attaquer
on s'arrangera je suis ravi d'être un
make up mais je suis preneur pour les
mal aimés note aussi la n'était pas mort
mais je vous assure qu'un de ces lois g8
à l'évier quand il est dans un milieu où
il y en avait beaucoup avec moi ce sera
noël avant l'heure comme exode avec josé
ça sent toujours sapin qui a les boules
pardon isabelle mais c'est de la merde
oui
[Rires]
non mais il a franchement pas bon ça a
marché parce que ça c'est ça c'est un
échange mars en une marchandise non
c'est qu'ils ont lu combat j'adore les
courses mais rarement sur le bon chemin
faisant les courses d'accord merci ça
continue vous savez ce que c'est que la
maiso faut ni la mise aux phobies bizri
misophonie qu'apple d'une soupe miso ces
pourparlers andrew de selmana et
s'envoyer un livre sur la mise au fond
ni c'est parce que c'est quelqu'un qui
ne supporte pas les bruits des bruits de
mastication tous les bruits de la vie sa
famille à son immersion absolument ça
lui fait du mal ce qui est faux initial
on va voir parce que c'est la haine des
souvent la raison valérie benaïm
certaines personnes ne supporte pas
d'entendre les bruits de notre quotidien
auquel c'est vrai la majorité des gens
qui font même pas attention
moi je m'en fous totalement voilà pas
rien mais il ya des gens ils bloquent
sur un truc mais dans 66 minutes et
anthony il devient fou quand il en tient
et d'antan son chien manger où on ses
enfants manger il peut péter les plombs
à cause du bruit de massification
alors regardez donc ce que toi tu es
mises au fond non non mais j'avais vu
une expo de bacon ou il filmée en gros
plan une bouche qui mastic à des
chercheurs parce que c'est que je ne
sais pas pourquoi il avait canard
peut-être qu'il était mise
miso phone déconner vous avez vu une
expo de bacon et plus sont maniés aux os
et aux moyens moyens c'est bon c'est bon
le problème c'est que je suis je suis un
peu la porte je l'entends je ne peux pas
rester quand ils mangent et quand il
boit c'est pire mais faut-il qu'ils
mangent des chips haussier des mains ça
agace tout le monde
malgré lui les bruits de mastication de
sa famille le rendent fous dans la
finalité carotte d'un moment ça commence
à bien faire
on a envie que la personne arrête de
faire du bruit et ça nous énerve mais en
pointe devenir potentiellement violents
ce matin quand j'ai trop petit déjeuner
des compères arrivée chez arrêter de
manger
alors c'est vrai très classe et un enfer
pour lui ces séries que j'ai un gros
problème avec les paquets de chips
ah ouais si j'ai une personne à côté qui
met 3 à ouvrir son paquet d'accords
marche en raquettes mais aussi chez
merck qui veulent les marchés marquent
la capitaine dans une piscine où vous
étiez qu'un accroc majeur
tu vois des mecs qui marchent en
claquettes non mais c'est vrai que vous
avez un truc qui vous énerve
qu'est ce qui m'énerve voir à pas de
loup cinéma qui menace qui mangent des
bonbons pendant trois heures ouvre
lentement le paquet de chips et ça dure
tout le film c'est ça ouais en fait je
pense qu'on est tous comme ça mais un
peu plus basse échelle exactement il ya
des bien sûr il ya un éventail qui
peuvent voilà voilà être plus en plus
atteindre que d'autres merci merci
docteur vdev devra faire conclut il y
avait pierre jean chalencon café le
encore le spectacle par exemple quand un
vendeur lui propose d'acheter une ancre
de bateau
celui qu'on surnomme pjc.a direct lui
trouver une nouvelle utilité
regardez vous tapez sexy sur internet et
vous tombez direct sur pierre jean
chalencon il échoue lui très chaud et
bouillon je trouve ya un côté art
contemporain
c'est à dire que toi tu peux faire du
thé d'huile sur le poteau la ville
adorée giacometti tu vois je mettrais
giacometti ça me rappelle ma copine love
amour qui faisait études en est une
[Musique]
et justement la saq et ça on va en
parler dans cette crise tard puisque
jeudi soir tf1 a tenté un truc de ouf
pour la première fois dans danse avec
les stars
ça n'était jamais arrivé je vous le dis
ils ont tenté de faire venir des gens
connus dans cette liste les bodin's
étaient présents toutes les missions ils
ont tout donné comme castaldi avec son
argent il a tout donné à ses ex regarde
si vous quittez mars et quart de finale
vous êtes tous invités ce soir alors mes
préférés denise et la juge à l'agitée
délicat
comment ça se passe et solide jeu je
kiffe ma mère très très sympathique pas
une fois de plus en tête de classement
une professionnelle est bien utile quand
tu sais je sais je le sais je le sais
jos alors dans danse avec les stars
l'inde un moment qu'il ya des moments
qui a été plus commenter toute la soirée
c'est la prestation de laetitia milot
qui était venue chanter son nouveau
titre loin d'ici avec vincent nick lowe
voilà loin d'ici c'est ce que vous
connaîtrez certains et la pauvre
laetitia que je kiffe s est fait
déglinguer sur les réseaux sociaux
regardez
dc
c'est parti donc ici
[Musique]
lortie
tout comme
[Musique]
six mois que tu
jean
[Musique]
j'ai quitté alors la plage en tout pas
aimé alors il ya des karine ferri aussi
dans danse avec les stars et karine
ferri elle donne les noms des gagnants
d'un jeu son cours pendant danse avec
les stars a pas dit un truc at tu fais
ça et tu traces et jeudi à une dame qui
a gagné 5000 euros une dame qui à mon
avis elle doit souvent hésité avant de
donner son nom de famille quand elles
réservent au restaurant à regarder comme
d'habitude toujours pour l'instant bravo
à madame pécule fadam pq qui vient de
remporter un chèque de 5000 euros
d'amendé
[Applaudissements]
bon c'est pas marrant c'est moi je me
moquais je crois qu'il faut pas se
moquer des noms de famille même en
classe et tout faux pas le faire moi je
faisais ce n'est pas fait c'est fou ça
quand vous mettez dans la neige
non mais quelle moto avec 7 alors c'est
aziz diabaté qui a été éliminé donc
jeudi en quarts de finale vraiment le
jeu actif pensaient qu'ils allaient
gagner je t'ai dit alors on va revoir sa
prestation avec sa partenaire denitsa
voilà qui embrasse aussi ils ont dansé
sur mon beau frère de blake mg je kiffe
et tout ce qui fait le teacch qui paie
les noms seraient et
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
est le bienvenu
alors danse avec les stars
il a à lille quoi téléphone jeudi soir
et c'est vrai que ça a été une
catastrophe pire score d'audience de
l'histoire de danse avec les stars 2,9
millions téléspectateurs il faut dire
que pour eux il y avait une très grosse
concurrence il y avait il y avait eu
scènes de ménages sur m6 il y avait
également quatre est bien marché
d'ailleurs merci à mes balances ton post
en prime avec yann moix qui a faim
cartons carton d'audience war demi cent
mille téléspectateurs
merci à vous et à moi que ça a annoncé
qu'il allait être donc à partir de la
semaine prochaine il sera avec vous
j'aimerais avoir l'avis des chroniqueurs
là dessus parce que c'est aussi de la
télé et c'est vrai que yann moix on va
rebondir donc chez éric alors il ya eu
un moment très très fort dans l'émission
où tout le monde va parler c'est lorsque
notre ami qu'on aime énormément
christine kelly a pris la parole après
le témoignage de yann moix
elle n'a pas pu retenir ses larmes car
elle aussi elle a subi des violences
pendant son enfance et l a dit un
témoignage très important
elle a dit qu'elle renonce elle
reconnaissait à se reconnaissaient ans
yann moix que ça parole d'un enfant
voilà exactement
et ça ça est un témoignage très très
fort beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de gens
en ont parlé regarde et je suis est très
bouleversée depuis le début de
l'émission pardonnez moi je vais essayer
de finir mes phrases mais l'exclusion de
la famille je reconnais que vous êtes
d'information la seule différence est
que justement tout les expertises que
lorsqu'on a été battue ou bien en
humiliation tour ou bien on se bat quand
toutes les humiliations et ma question
pour faire simple c'est que j'ai
l'impression vous savez choisi
d'humilier à votre tour
involontairement les dessins antisémites
prouve que vous avez été un enfant battu
et lorsqu'on a été un enfant battu je
peux vous dire qu'on comprend tout ce
que vous dites tout ce que vous dites et
qu'on ne laisse pas une seconde nous
seule seconde place au doute
pardonnez moi
sur les réseaux sociaux étaient très
partagés un bien sûr sur yann moix qui a
des gens qui disent merci d'avoir invité
yann moix dans l'émission de ce soir il
m'a bouleversée en expliquant son enfant
c'est affreux de subir de telles
violences de ses parents bravo pour son
parcours professionnel qui est
talentueux je le comprends mieux
maintenant et puis y'a des tweets voilà
qui dit yann moix avec toutes ses
excuses aurait-il fait si les dessins
étaient restés secrets
évidemment non donc comment croire à sa
sincérité et il a dit qu'il aurait pas
fait des lieux il a été honnête il a dit
que si les dessins n'était pas sorti non
n'auraient plus à jamais à paris